one of tonight's documentary features
nominees alexander manuela calls his
approach
observational storytelling which seems
like a really good definition
of what a documentary should be
their impact can be extraordinary
whether it's a
full-length feature film or a cell phone
video
taken by a young woman in minneapolis by
the name of darnella fraser
that became the catalyst for change
here are the nominees for documentary
feature
collective alexander nanao and bianca
wanna
[ __ ] camp nicole newnam jim lebrecht
and sarah boulder the mall agent maite
alberti
and marcella santibanez my octopus
teacher
pippa ehrlich james reed and craig
foster
time garrett bradley lauren domino
and kellen quinn
and the oscar goes to
my octopus teacher pippa ehrlich
jade reed and craig foster
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you to the academy um and thank
you to all of our
incredible nominees who spent so many
years and i presume a lot of tears
making beautiful and important films
and bringing them into the world
i'd like to thank craig foster
and his family especially tom and swati
who
opened their hearts and supported us
every step of the way and fed us and
allowed their home to become
a production company for three years um
i want to thank our production partners
at off the fence especially inn and
windemouth and sam
barton humphreys who believed in this
film
before it was anything we want to thank
netflix for enabling us to share our
story with the world
and then our incredible
octopus team whose arms stretch across
the planet from south africa
to amsterdam to the uk to the us
roger and warren for beautiful
cinematography
dan and jinx for incredible patience and
editing
kevin and barry and kyle and all the
people at the refinery
and of the incredible sea change project
who's been in the background
supporting us the whole way along and
and caring so much for the great african
sea forest which is
where the octopus lived um
and our friends and family who put up
with years and years of tunnel vision
um if in many and i know there are
many south africans who are awake in the
middle of the night
to watch the ceremony and
in many ways this really is a tiny
personal story
that played out in a sea forest at the
very tip of africa
but on a more universal level i hope
that it provided
a glimpse of a different kind of
relationship between human beings
and the natural world
thank you and i don't have a lot to add
to that pippa
covered it very well um it's a great and
totally overwhelming honor to be here
and so thank you so much to the academy
and
and all the incredible films that were
in our category it's it's really
humbling and amazing
and i'd also like to thank my family um
rosie and isabelle and my mom and my two
sisters
jenny and janice um i don't think i'd be
here
today without their sort of level of
love and support so thank you very much
and
i think final extra thank you for for
craig who
while it was such an enormous team
making this film in the end it sort of
began and ended with him and it's his
story
and he kind of showed us that
you know if if a man can kind of form a
friendship with
with an octopus it does sort of make you
wonder what else is possible
so thank you craig and cheers everyone
you